speaking of Putin Edward Snowden just
got given Russian citizenship
congratulations congratulations Snowden
I'm sure that you've worked long and
hard for that what do you think what's
what's your thoughts there yeah so I
feel like there's a lot of I understand
the debate out there about whether or
not snowden's decision was good for
America or bad for America whether it
was legal or illegal whether he's a
criminal or a hero
but there's also a certain element that
you are Who Your Friends Are and right
now Russia just granted him citizenship
which shows that he is he is serving the
Russian interests you don't give
citizenship to somebody who isn't
serving your own national interests so
we know for sure that Snowden is serving
the Russian interests now does that mean
that that Russian interests were to give
away all of his inside at NSA maybe or
our Russian interests simply to create
uh ongoing frustration in the Ukraine
Russia crisis right now by making a a
very public figure now a hero of the
Russian people
maybe but regardless what we have here
is we have an American citizen who
whether he intended to or not he is now
you know a representation of of the
greatness of Russia uh and and he
himself continues to be this
controversial character for the United
States itself and I'll go one step
further to say Chris that that what
Snowden did by by whistleblowing on the
the Patriot Act and the collection
against U.S citizens what he did there
is largely without question there's
there's not many people in the
intelligence Community who criticize him
for that specific act it's the fact that
he stole a bunch of other compartmented
secrets that had nothing to do with that
and he kept those as like a just in case
insurance policy and then he also
compromised those secrets that had
nothing to do with collection again what
were those what were the second sets
that he stole so a lot of those remain
classified but those were it was a
secret it was missions and operations
that we were doing outside of the realm
of counterterrorism collection within
the United States and the the fact that
he stole those and downloaded those and
carried them on a thumb drive and and
continued to use those as chips if you
go back and you look at the snowden's
history he moved from place to place
from Hong Kong to Ecuador to Russia and
every time he just gave a little bit
more right he kind of bought his next he
bought his next airplane ticket if you
will with a new secret and that's the
piece that makes people so upset that's
what is technically makes makes him a
wanted man in the United States not that
he whistle blue on on a program that was
later determined to be illegal but that
he took this insurance policy with him
that actually made him uh you know in
violation of the Espionage Act
unpresumably
Maybe
the agency knows what he has
but also I guess maybe not depending on
the ability to track what he pulls off
on a thumb drive maybe the digital
security be sufficient to know what it
is but he could have given back 10 and
still have 90 percent
correct we and nobody knows what he's
given but they do know what he's taken
and then it's to your point it's the
it's the it's the digital the digital
piece he only had access to certain
programs according to his clearance and
according to his you know rights he only
had download rights to certain programs
so we were you know that's that's
something that the NSA gets to deal with
on their own to decide exactly what
those programs were and what the damage
was
um but nobody nobody who is in who is
satisfied with solely being a
whistleblower takes the extra just in
case nobody else you know premeditates
how they're going to continue to flee
custody when they think they're doing
the right thing and I think that's the
piece that gets overlooked oftentimes
because everybody focuses on the program
to collect under the Patriot Act nobody
thinks about the secondary and tertiary
programs that he also took to help pay
his way to protection for the last
decade I guess he foresaw the
incoming shitstorm that he was gonna
have to deal with and this was his yeah
I suppose that that turns the situation
I hadn't heard about this before but it
it changes the situation from being a
single Noble patriot who is doing his
duty for the country to
someone that that feels a little bit
more selfish it feels a little bit more
like he has an agenda he's looking out
for himself and I understand the
motivation we're all looking to preserve
our own life and freedom and liberty and
who am I to say that I wouldn't do the
same thing in his situation as well but
I would agree I didn't know about that
but I think that you're right had he
have been the completely selfless actor
doing something to call the powerful to
account maybe he would have got
epsteined maybe not but he wouldn't be
the same type of um
distasteful actor I think that he's seen
now yeah and it's very interesting
because it just shows how you know the
lens of History especially in the world
of Espionage the lens of history is
short it's uh it's it we remember the
big things and we forget the small
things and in the first weeks and months
and the first two or three big moves
that Snowden made uh it all of this was
very public knowledge it was very
publicly you know we were all publicly
aware that he stole the the you know
this specific program and others but
then over time the and others became
something nobody talked about and then
now there's this you know huge movement
about you know Snowden is a hero because
he you know the the court system later
found that this one program was in fact
illegal
nobody doubt nobody debates that right I
even I don't debate that I just I've
always said he did the right thing the
wrong way and I know I get criticized
saying that that's a cop-out answer but
I don't know of a better answer than
that you don't end up a Russian citizen
by doing the right thing the right way
you end up a Russian citizen by doing
something something wrong along the way
how much do you think Russia could have
given to him citizenship to get access
to some of the information that he's got
and if he was to start to reveal the
stuff that he hasn't yet rescinded does
that I mean he's already
quite a high Public Enemy or at least a
private enemy an agency enemy I suppose
that would I'm going to guess make him
even more of a a concern even more of a
worry yeah what's hard now is
um Snowden is always he's always been
seen by the American government as a
fugitive but now he runs the risk of
becoming a combatant because now that
he's a Russian citizen if he
participates in some sort of uh cyber
warfare or digital Warfare or if he if
he assists their intelligence Services
operating against American citizens now
he's become a a for and after now he's
become a combatant in a large-scale
conflict that's actively happening in
Europe that to me the fact that he was
granted citizenship so close to the
mobilization of 300 troops so close to
the threat of nuclear uh retaliation out
of Russia against Ukraine you know on
the heels uh or on the the the front toe
tips of of a midterm election in the
United States this is very much an
inform Nation Warfare kind of move it's
not that he gave something new it's not
that he did something new maybe they've
been looking at granting them
citizenship for months they were just
waiting for the right time
but the danger that he has now is he
goes from being an exiled fugitive to
potentially being an actual Target
because you know I it depends on whether
or not the he rescinded his American
citizenship or if he retains his
American citizenship but we know that
terrorists who were also American
citizens became targets for kinetic
strikes
if he steps into that combative role or
that combatant role he may very well end
up on the same list what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]